et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
donc j'ai un volant bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous vous êtes la
maire socialiste de nantes et la
directrice de campagne d'anne hidalgo on
va bien sûr parler de cette campagne
nous mettons ensemble pendant votre
visite pour une interview en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale
dont jean stéphane bern et bonjour
bonjour qui dirige que vous connaissez
bien évidemment juin à roland qui
dérivent la rédaction parisienne du
journal ouest france on commence par
l'actualité et c'est l'ouverture
aujourd'hui du procès des meurtriers de
mireille knoll qui sont jugés pour
meurtre antisémite devant les assises de
paris procès qui arrive quelques mois
après l affaire sarah halimi est ce que
vous êtes inquiète aujourd'hui juin à
roland d'une montée l'antisémitisme en
france je suis inquiète de cette montée
de l'antisémitisme et plus globalement
j'allais dire d'une montée d'une forme
de violence qu'elle soit larvée ou
exprimer et je le dis je crois que dans
ce contexte le débat public le débat
démocratique doit gagner en hauteur et
doit gagner en sérénité quand on a une
société qui à ce niveau
de fragmentation et de colère je crois
que la parole publique elle doit être
pesé et mesuré maintenant qu'ils aient
imagine que vous avec quelques noms en
tête en voyant ces hasards je dis
clairement enfin le tour que prend ce
début de campagne présidentielle est
préoccupant est préoccupant on va pas
parler pendant six mois du prénom des
enfants mois les français sur le terrain
il nous parle du pouvoir d'achat nous
parle de logement il nous parle
d'éducation on n'a pas le droit de
collectivement de leur confisquer le
débat présidentiel le débat démocratique
il est là pour partir des réalités des
habitants et pour que chacun propose le
projet de société auquel il croit et
pour ça je pense qu'il ya besoin de
respect d'abord on peut avoir des
positions politiques diamétralement
différente c'est la noblesse du débat
démocratique mais il ya cette forme
d'exemplarité je crois de la parole
publique et puis de fermeté pour revenir
à votre question de départ à chaque fois
qu'il ya un acte antisémite il doit être
sanctionné à chaque fois qu'il ya un
acte raciste il doit l'être et quand
j'entends parfois il compris je vais
vous donner un exemple quand j'entends
sur des plateaux
des presque candidat ou candidat à la
présidentielle qui prononce des mots qui
font référence à des faits qui doivent
être sanctionnés par la loi et que
parfois ça ne réagit même pas en plateau
oui je me dis que nous avons une forme
de responsabilité collective à ramener
de la sérénité dans le débat public on
s'habille l'it et des politiques et des
journalistes je vais mettre les pieds
dans le plat parce que vous avez double
mot fait allusion à eric zemmour sans le
citer est-ce que c'est lui qui confie ce
que la campagne et comment est ce que
vous expliquez qu'il parvienne à lui
seul a entraîné tous les autres où
quasiment tous les autres dans son
sillage sur des thématiques qui comme
vous venez de lire pose problème est ce
que je constate d'abord c'est que
aujourd'hui monsieur zemmour n'apporte
aucune réponse aux questions concrètes
que nous pose des français ça c'est la
première source de la deuxième chose que
je constate comme directrice de campagne
wendel go c'est que de plus en plus on
ne dit pas que pensent-ils d'anne
hidalgo sur l'éducation qu'est ce
qu'elle pense sur le pouvoir d'achat on
nous demande qu'est ce qu'elle pense
comme pour tous les autres candidats sur
les propos d'eric zemmour et c'est ça
qui n'est pas possible ça c'est plutôt
notre faute à nous journalistes je pense
que il ya une attention collective à
avoir dans le moment que chacun doit
prendre sa part aux responsables
politiques de proposer des offres
crédibles qui font envie et qui crée du
débat à nous d'être capables de poser
des sujets qui vont interpeller pour
pour sortir de ce côté un peu le bruit
et la fureur qui lasse croyez moi sur le
terrain les habitantes sont sont lassés
de ce qui finit par représente
ressemblait plus à un spectacle que un
débat qui part de leurs questions à eric
zemmour ils ne posent pas sur la table
des thèmes est ce qu'il ne répond pas à
des angoisses justifiée ou non de la
part de certains français qui ont
peut-être été mises sous le tapis
pendant des années pendant les
politiques il doit ya aucun sujet tabou
je vais vous dire je fais partie de
cette gauche qui assume les sujets de
sécurité je pense qu'il faut poser tous
ces sujets mais maintenant c'est oublié
pendant longtemps par une partie de la
non sécurité d'immigration à la vous
remontez peut-être à la gauche dit à un
moment excusez moi mais je vais vous
parler de ce que je connais le mieux les
maires en responsabilité dans les
grandes villes je peux vous dire que les
sujets de sécurité pardonnez moi de vous
le dire comme je le pense mais se les
coltiner tous les jours c'est tous les
jours qu'on fait ce travail dans un lien
pas si simple à trouver avec l'état
puisque historiquement dans notre pays
la sécurité était une compétence
quasiment unique et régalienne de l'état
regardez ce qui s'est passé ces dix
dernières années
plus ça va plus les maires s'engagent
chez moi à nantes je vais recruter 70
policiers municipaux dans le mandat en
dix ans j'aurais doubler les effectifs
de la police municipale et pour autant
si vous posez la question aux nantaises
et aux nantais et vous diront qu'on a
encore des progrès à faire en matière de
sécurité et c'est vrai ce que je veux
dire par là c'est qu'aujourd'hui il ya
un débat parmi les élus locaux qui est
de dire est ce que les élus ont raison
continue à s'engager sur ces sujets ou
est-ce qu'en faisant ça finalement on
perd mais pas l'état de se délester de
ce sujet moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
que au bout du compte on est du mieux
pour les citoyens on va parler d'un
autre sujet qui inquiète les français
c'est la crise sanitaire bien évidemment
le texte qui prolonge le passé ni terre
va arriver au sénat il est cette semaine
d'ailleurs au sénat le sénat à majorité
de droite veut sortir de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et propose que le
recours aux passes annie terre ne soit
plus possible au delà du 28 février et
ils proposent de territorialiser le pass
c'est à dire que le pass ne doit plus
être appliquées dans les départements où
plus de 75 % de la population est
vaccinée est ce que vous êtes favorable
à cette territorialisation
moi je suis d'abord favorable à la
vaccination obligatoire je le dis parce
que sauf que ça c'est pas passer au
sénat absolument mais vous me demandez
ce que j'en pense qu'aujourd'hui
je pense que maintenant on cherche des
solutions qui peuvent avoir une
efficacité sur le moment mais soyons
prudents rappelons nous les choses
bougent très vite les choses bougent
très très vite et la volatilité du
niveau de l'épidémie d'un territoire à
un autre ce qui est vrai un jour n'est
pas forcément vrai la semaine d'après
donc je suis prudente je ne dis pas que
cette initiative ne présenteraient pas
d'intérêt mais je crois qu'elle ne règle
pas le sujet tout ça veut dire vous êtes
inquiète d'une possible reprise de
l'épidémie non je suis pas inquiète
aujourd'hui mais je suis attentive et
nous sommes
nous les maires les yeux fixés sur les
chiffres les indicateurs il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui de signaux
d'alert préoccupant mais nous devons
rester vigilants nous devons je crois à
continuer d'appeler aussi un à la
responsabilité au respect des gestes
barrières dont on voit bien mais je vais
prendre un exemple de la vie de tous les
jours le nombre de louisa on sait plus
exactement comment on se dit bonjour on
recommence à se faire la bise ou pas ça
peut paraître exotique je crois que ça
ne l'est pas on est dans une zone de
flottement là et il faut continuer sur
le prêt sanitaires ont territorialise ou
pas on le garde j'ai un doute sur ce
sujet je ne suis pas totalement
convaincu parce que je crois que les
choses peuvent bouger trop vite pour que
ça finisse pas par se transformer dans
une usine à gaz mais soyons clairs le
vous parlez de vigilance est ce que du
coup c'est quand même intéressant de de
prolonger le cadre légal sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire tel que le demande
le gouvernement et y compris le pass
sanitaire où vous seriez pour pour pour
y mettre fin
tout simplement je voulais me dis
d'emblée je pense vraiment que la bonne
solution c'était la vaccination
obligatoire et plus de crise mais en
fait on peut en débattre quand même
parce que la vie démocratique elle doit
permettre de dire qu'est ce qui nous
semble la meilleure option je le dis
parce que la vaccination a beaucoup
progressé mais vous savez comme moi que
dans un certain nombre de milieux
populaires par exemple dans un certain
nombre de nos quartiers on n'a pas
encore atteint un taux de vaccination
alors quand vient se rajouter aux
inégalités sociales les inégalités de
santé alors que beaucoup a été fait pour
aller vers comme on dit aujourd'hui pour
aller chercher donc moi je n'ai pas
envie qu'on fasse l'économie de ce débat
de fond sur cette question de la
fracture territoriale emmanuel macron il
était hier dans la loire en déplacement
et parmi les annonces il veut accélérer
la réindustrialisation des territoires
et à 650 millions d'euros du plan de
relance qui sont attribuées pour des
projets de réhabilitation de friches
industrielles vous le soutenez sur ce
point là le chef de l'état bien sûr que
vouloir réindustrialiser le pays et ses
territoires c'est une bonne chose mais
quand même et s'éprend mal c'est ça non
mais c'est un peu gros non on est à cinq
mois des élections présidentielles c'est
président de la république qui parle ou
c'est le candidat
donc oui bien sûr il faut le faire mais
j'aurai avec le président de la
république le face avant est élu il a
bien sûr quand même même vous le même
genre de prévenance concernant le plan
france 2030 tout le tout le tout la
volonté de réindustrialiser pays où là
il est dans l'exercice normal compte
tenu des circonstances de sa présidence
vous allez entre les deux quand même
qu'il dise quelle est sa vision pour
l'avenir du pays c'est bien logique
qu'il le fasse dans un délai tellement
rapprochés avec des sommes quand même
engagé elles sont débattues où ces
sommes à quel moment le parlement est
saisi de ces sujets dans quel projet de
loi de finances s'est inscrit commencé
dans le projet de loi de finances
examiné enfin vous voyez bien qu'on est
sur une échelle il le dit lui-même qui
dépasse largement de ça et puis après on
peut dire un mot sur le fond aussi moi
ce que je constate dans ce plan c'est au
moins trois choses la première une
ambition que je considère trop faible
sur la question d'énergie cantons
renouvelables ça c'est la première
dimension la deuxième une absence totale
des territoires c'est à dire qu'on parle
de la relance du pays on sait tous que
dans ce pays 70% de l'investissement
public passe par les territoires et les
territoires sont absents de ce plan
c'est quand même révélateur d'un
fonctionnement ultra centralisé ultra
jacobins et une nouvelle fois que la
nouvelle étape de la décentralisation et
pas franchement au rendez vous et puis
enfin la dimension sociale la dimension
de la lutte des inégalités que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure force est de
constater qu'une nouvelle fois elle est
un point aveugle total du plan du
gouvernement avant de passer aux
énergies renouvelables juste un point
sur vous avez évoqué à plusieurs
reprises le pouvoir d'achat qui est la
préoccupation majeure en ce moment là
sur sur le chèque enfin pas le chèque
mais le l'indemnité l'inflation est ce
que vous pensez que le gouvernement est
à et
apporter une réponse à côté j'ai
commencé je vais vous donner un exemple
une femme qui gagne 2000 50 euros par
mois et qui a trois enfants n'a pas le
ch rien c'est injuste c'est pas ça la
réalité de la vie des françaises et des
français aujourd'hui c'est pour cette
raison qu anne hidalgo elle a fait une
proposition très clair très tôt 1 je le
dis parce que factuellement elle a été
la première à faire cette proposition en
disant à circonstance exceptionnelle
mesures exceptionnelles
demande de considérer que c'est un
produit de première nécessité et donc
baisse de la tva en conséquence au début
quand elle l'a dit on à 10 ans baisse
des taxes sur le carburant c'est une
drôle d'idée quand même c'est un peu
trop les lignes ont commencé à bouger un
en europe certains s'interrogent sur
cette mesure je crois que là il ya
clairement un manque d'anticipation et
vraiment c'est pas trop être idiot est
ce que c'est pas aussi visées des
français qui ont les moyens de se payer
ce surplus plein d'essence alors que la
mesure de l'état si peu plus les classes
moyennes et les classes populaires ne
cible pas les classes moyennes justement
la mesure de l'état c'est bien ce que je
lui reproche rien à faire c'est que les
classes moyennes ne sont pas touchés et
quand vous échanger avec les hommes et
les femmes c'est bien ça qui vous disent
ce sont ceux qui travaillent ceux qui
ont été affaiblis par la crise c'est
typiquement un couple où l'un travaille
en intérim et l'autre faisait des heures
supplémentaires qu'il ne fait plus
aujourd'hui c'est ce qu'ils vous disent
aujourd'hui et bien moi dans ma vie je
choisis entre l'inscription de ma fille
à la danse et puis le fait de partir en
vacances cet été c'est de cela dont on
parle et ça ça peut pas se décider loin
dans un bureau déconnecté des réalités
et j'insiste le fait de présenter sa
sous forme de chèque ou dette directe
est ce que vous estimez que c'est une
bonne solution c'est encore une fois
fait partie d'une espèce de d'une aide
qui pourrait qui pourrait apparaître
très opportune
du fait de la proximité de la présence
pour le coup ce serait pas correct de ma
part de dire il ya un sujet il faut
prendre des mesures ne reprochez qu'une
mesure soit prise vous voyez ce serait
pas cohérent ce que je conteste en
revanche c'est la mesure je crois
vraiment que la mesure ne prend pas le
poids de ce qui se passe aujourd'hui
dans le pays sur le pouvoir d'achat et
et on devrait avoir tous en alerte ce
sujet parce que quand ces questions
montrent autant qu'elles sont en train
de monter en ce moment on évoquait tout
à l'heure la crispation du pays la
colère ces sujets du quotidien ils sont
prégnants et je crois vraiment qu'on
doit les regarder avec beaucoup
d'attention qu'on va parler de cette
question de l'énergie puisque rte le
gestionnaire du réseau électrique
français a remis son rapport très
attendu
on dit qu'il faut développer davantage
les renouvelables mais il dit aussi que
l'objectif de notre invité carbone ne
pourra pas être atteint sans le
nucléaire ça veut dire qu'elle
pro-nucléaire avez raison mais ce
rapport quand on le lit il dit surtout
que c'est une question de choix
politique puisque en réalité ce rapport
et propose six scénarios et que ces six
scénarios propose des proportions
différentes entre nucléaire et le
renouvelable nous ce que nous disons
c'est que l'on doit aller plus loin sur
le développement des énergies
renouvelables je crois qu'il ya de
manière de plus en plus compliqué
effectivement il ya plusieurs parts de
mix dans l'est dans les priorités pour
vous c'est quoi la bonne part moi je
pense qu'on doit être clair sur la
trajectoire pour moi la trajectoire
c'est que la priorité doit être donnée
aux renouvelables et que tant qu'on
n'est pas à 100% renouvelable la part du
nucléaire s'adapte à la part du redoux
l' epad inverse l'inversé de dire on
continue nucléaire et puis on a une
petite part de renouvelables moi le
choix politique que je porte et le choix
politique que porte anne hidalgo et
l'ensemble de l'équipe qui est derrière
elle c'est de dire non la priorité elle
est renouvelable et donc 50% de
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique
absolument sauf quartier ça va coûter
cher attention c'est peut-être pas comme
ça qu'on va atteindre la neutralité
carbone pour vous il faut quand même
aller vers plus de 50% de bonnes jambes
je le redis dans le rapport d'rtl on a
six scénarios et donc la responsable
avec les conséquences que ça sonne et
manquant même de finances publiques
confirme deuxième en élite et carbone je
n'oublie pas non plus les salariés qui
travaillent dans ce domaine un parce que
moi je crois qu'on fera pas la
transition écologique sans les salariés
qui sont concernés j'en parle en
connaissance de cause je suis sur un
territoire on à la centrale de cordemais
sujet à nouveau d'actualité
on ne fait pas la transition écologique
contre les salariés donc je dis c'est
une question de choix politique même si
ça vaut plus cher nous nous considérons
qu'on doit donner la priorité aux
renouvelables je ne dis pas qu'on est
capable de faire 100 % renouvelable tout
de suite je ne le crois pas en revanche
je pense qu'on doit avoir une claire et
dire le nucléaire doit s'adapter aux
renouvelables dans ce mixte que vous et
vos caresses but il faudrait peut-être
préciser pour les téléspectateurs sujet
cordemais sujets d'actualité parce que
la présidente de la région pays de la
loire a proposé ou annoncé qu'elle était
favorable à l'expérimentation d'un d'un
mini d'une mini centrale accorde mais
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
bonne idée ou issue défavorable sur le
fond comme sur la forme je suis
défavorable sur le fond et puis sur la
forme quand même c'est oublier
l'histoire de notre territoire un
territoire qui a lutté contre
l'implantation au carnet 0 concertation
avec les acteurs économiques et
politiques du territoire sincèrement
j'ai été très surprise on a des
convictions politiques différentes avec
la présidente de région mais d'ordinaire
on travaille bien ensemble là aucune
concertation une annonce en pleine
séance sur un sujet aussi sensible
franchement c'était pour le moins
surprenant juste un mot pour finir sur
ces questions puisque on va parler de
l'écologie emmanuel macron pourrait
devrait annoncer la création de nouveaux
repères dit si d'ici noël pour vous ça
doit se faire cette construction de
nouveaux repères ou pas mais je crois
d'abord qu'il faut qu'il y ait un débat
sur ce sujet enfin sur une question de
cette nature sur une question aussi
sensible en termes de sécurité pour le
pays en termes de conséquences
potentielles en termes d'emploi pardon
mais ça ne s'annonce pas d'un coup de
chapeau comme ça sur une carte enfin il
va lui falloir se dire parlement dans un
sens c'est nouveau je vous dis y'a un
rapport qui est sorti ce rapport rtl ce
rapport il est dans le débat donc
maintenant les acteurs doit s'en saisir
le parlement doit s'en saisir moi moi je
les aimais le contraire oui aussi mais
vraiment enfin pourvues soit l'addition
de l' équilibre des pouvoirs ce sujet
doit être débattu au parlement quand
même c'est c'est un sujet majeur et de
l'autonomie du pays et de la trajectoire
qu'on va prendre dans les prochaines
années enfin on met on voit bien que le
débat de fond uni tout simple c'est que
si on veut décarbonés le l'économie
française il faut avoir recours
massivement à l'électricité et à une
électricité décarbonée comment c'est
possible si on veut décarbonés tous les
secteurs de l'économie on va on va on va
vers une consommation d'électricité qui
va augmenter de manière phénoménale
comment on peut assumer cette
consommation si on développe pas où on
maintient pas le nucléaire je vous ai
pas dit que j'étais pour un nucléaire 0
demain je
ne crois pas que ce soit pour les genres
en revanche très simplement 520 leclerc
25 c'est possible pour dans ce contexte
vous pouviez tout à l'heure la question
du plan de relance et du plan 2030
sincèrement ce qu'il ya sur les énergies
renouvelables est faible je vous donne
un exemple concret chez moi à nantes on
a multiplié par cinq la production du
photovoltaïque en six ans hier hier
j'étais à inaugurer avec le groupe la
poste le plus grand toit photovoltaïque
d'une entreprise privée chez moi à un
moment donné il ya une question de
volonté et pas simplement de volonté
publique nous on le fait on met des
moyens sur la table mais on le fait
aussi en bonne intelligence avec les
acteurs privés qui eux mêmes des moyens
et ça c'est le rôle du politique de dire
quelle est la trajectoire et donc moi je
souhaite qu'on soit plus ambitieux que
ça sur la trajectoire du renouvelable on
topic c'est pas 100% renouvelable demain
chacun sait que ce n'est pas possible
mais si on fixe pas le cap si on fixe
pas la priorité eh bien on est
spectateur du réchauffement climatique
et des anges et ce sujet du coup ils
s'invitent évidemment dans la campagne
présidentielle quand on entend olivier
faur encore ce week end la transition
écologique ne doit pas se faire sur le
dos des classes moyennes et des classes
populaires qui n'en peuvent plus est-ce
que vous adhérez à ces propose que c'est
pour vous une manière de vous distinguer
des écologistes et les écologistes
aujourd'hui ce sont vos amis et futurs
vos adversaires
les écologistes se sont pas nos
adversaires
mais ce sujet ce n'est pas une question
de positionnement par rapport aux
écologistes c'est une question de
positionnement par rapport aux français
moi je suis intimement mêmes relations
humaines écologie a tué sociales sont
les deux facettes d'une même bataille et
que le sujet c'est qu'est l'écologie on
veut est ce qu'on veut une écologie
aussi pour les plus modestes c'est ce
qu'on veut une écologie qui le dessert
la ceinture en quelque sorte est ce
qu'on veut dire aux plus pauvres aux
plus modestes et aux classes moyennes la
transition écologique elle se fera avec
vous ça c'est un sujet absolument majeur
c'est un sujet qu'on connaît bien dans
nos villes je vais vous donner un
exemple concret quand on augmente le bio
dans nos cantines on peut augmenter le
bio dans les cantines pour tout le monde
et laisser les tarifs augmentent et on
peut augmenter le bio dans les cantines
et prendre soin comme on le fait à
nantes et dans d'autres endroits que on
reste à moins d'un euro pour les plus
modestes c'est un choix politique ce
choix politique c'est de mettre la
transition écologique au service du plus
grand nombre et est donc ce moment
présidentielle il doit aussi être là
pour définir des options
oui bonjour de l'est voient la
différence entre anne hidalgo et yannick
jadot sur cette question d'écologie on a
compris sur le social puisqu'il ya une
dalle go on l'a encore vu samedi elle
insiste beaucoup sur la question sociale
mais sur l'écologie c'est quoi la vient
jeu et je crois qu anne hidalgo porte
une écologie plus populaires dans le
projet qu'elle défend aujourd'hui pour
le pays et yannick jadot peut-être plus
punitives ça non je ne dirais pas plus
punitives jeudi plus populaires pour moi
c'est pas le même sujet le sujet c est
ce que on embarque ses classes moyennes
et ses classes populaires est ce que
quand on parle de l'alimentation du bio
est ce que quand on parle de la lutte
contre les passoires thermiques et
énergétiques
on parlait tout à l'heure des enjeux
d'énergie dans le logement on sait que
c'est une décharge première des ménages
dans les charges des ménages combien
partent en chauffage et sur tous les
sujets est ce qu'on les passe au tamis
d'une grille de lecture pouvoir d'achat
combien ça coûte aux gens et ce concert
la question sociale et la question la
lutte quand on vous disait tout à
l'heure les écologistes ce ne sont pas
nos adversaires ça veut dire qu'un
accord est encore possible entre vous et
moi je pense qu'il faut toujours
dialoguer mais en même temps on va
brasser ses lacs alors et vous qui gérez
la campagne zen d'algos il ya encore un
dialogue à l'heure actuelle sont certes
chez chacun ira dans ce sens bien sûr
qu'il ya un dialogue heureusement qu'il
ya un dialogue en revanche
notre priorité aujourd'hui c'est de
parler aux françaises et aux français
vous rendez compte quand même
aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes 70 % des
français n'ont pas encore fait leur
choix ça veut dire qu on est au tout
début de la campagne on a six mois
devant nous donc l'enjeu d'abord c'est
qu'on intéresse les français je suis pas
certaine que quand ils ont l'impression
qu'on se parle entre nous en permanence
ils aient l'impression qu'on leur parle
e donc nous notre sujet c'est leur
parler à eux ouais donc le psy vous
entends bien c'est on laisse se dérouler
la campagne et les choses s'installer et
puis après on peut faire quelques
réglages parce qu'aujourd'hui vous avez
sandrine rousseau qui appelle année
d'algos rejoindre les écologistes vous
avez arnaud de montebourg qu'estime qui
peut pas y avoir d'union de la gauche
possible en dehors de son projet et
finalement on a l'impression que vous
êtes tous d'accord sur une chose et une
seule c'est tous derrière moi
moi je sais et je sens qu'elle est
parfois l'interrogation parfois même le
désarroi d'une partie du peuple de
gauche de cette situation je crois qu'il
faut dire moi je la sens et je la mesure
donc oui des échanges doivent continuer
mais pas en vase clos enfin je leur dis
et ce n'est pas dans mes temps de vous
organiser un débat public entre les
différents candidats à ce stade que
chacun continue de porter ses
propositions que chacun s'adresse aux
vaisseaux cette année doit s'arrêter
quand est-ce qu'il ira jusqu'au 10 avril
à un moment il y aura les lignes il
reste six mois vraiment je le redis pour
moi la priorité aujourd'hui c'est
d'aller chercher ceux qui ne croient
plus c'est d'aller chercher les
abstentionnistes on va pas faire comme
si on avait oublié que aux municipales
aux départementales et régionales
on a eu un niveau extrêmement élevé
d'abstentionnistes et ma conviction
c'est que leurs questions à eux c'est ce
qui va se passer là est-ce que ça va
répondre à mes sujets amazonie un
dernier match d'arles et santé est ce
qu'on va parler logement est ce qu'on va
parler sécurité c'est aujourd'hui notre
priorité un dernier mot en juin à roland
puisque le temps file il ya une enquête
au doxa pour les chaînes parlementaires
est la presse régionale parues ce matin
qui dit que 74% des français trouvent
que nidal go est une mauvaise candidate
est peut-être plus inquiétant pour vous
vous allez nous le dira 49% des
sympathisants de gauche qui pense la
même chose ça vous inquiète quand même
d'abord on a six mois pour quoi un cri
puis je vous inviterai bien à lire ce
qu'on écrit les excellents confrères de
ouest france non je le dis parce que
mais là c'est pas un sondage d'intention
de poche non mais je suis gentille elle
sur l'image j'élargis quand même la
question si vous le permettez
on est quand même dans une forme de
frénésie sondagière on en a trois par
semaine excusez moi mais c'est pour
certains aussi
un business assez avantageux permettez
moi de vous le dire comme je le pense
est-ce que c'est inutile non est-ce que
ça dépend de la manière dont c'est fait
et du sérieux avec lequel ces faits oui
est-ce que six mois de débat
présidentiel peut se résumer à qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce qui n'est qu'une
photographie à l'instant t eh bien nous
avec anne hidalgo rentrera pas là dedans
on sera sur le terrain chaque jour
auprès des français auprès des sages
femmes dans les hôpitaux auprès des
ouvriers qui se demandent si la
transition écologique va bien se faire
avec eux auprès des mères de familles en
situation monoparentale pour lesquels on
propose par exemple un service public de
la petite enfance et on a parlé de ce
sujet ce matin merci beaucoup merci
d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]